MURAT YENER: With
Android Q, apps
can offer a full edge-to-edge
screen experience,
regardless of whether
gestures or buttons are
enabled for navigation.
All apps targeting
Q in the Play Store
should move to implementing
an edge-to-edge experience
by drawing app content
from the top screen
edge to the bottom screen edge.
The recommended
way to achieve this
is to render the app content
under a transparent nav bar.
In order to make your app render
content under the nav bar,
start by making the
navigation bar transparent.
You can also make the status
bar transparent to get
the full height of the screen.
You can do this by setting
your theme as shown here.
For API 29, it's heavily
encouraged to implement this.
And note that apps
can optionally
do this before API 29.
Alternatively, you can
make the navigation bar
transparent
programmatically by setting
navigation bar color and status
bar color on a window object.
Starting with
Android Q, the system
is responsible for providing
background protection
of navbar elements, such
as buttons and bars,
against app contents.
On higher-end
devices, this means
if an app requests a
transparent nav bar, the system
will adjust the nav
bar's UI color based
on the content drawn behind it.
For example, if you
have a dark background,
the system will
provide a light UI.
On devices with
lower performance,
the system is still responsible
for drawing a translucent nav
bar.
It draws a light or dark
screen behind the system UI
depending on whether the app
requested light or dark system
buttons in the nav bar.
You also need to set the system
UI visibility flags to extend
underneath the system bars so
your app can render content
under the nav bar.
The system UI visibility
APIs on the view objects
allows a number of
flags to be set.
The most common flags you will
use for edge-to-edge experience
are shown here.
When these flags are
specified together,
you're telling the
system that you
want your app to be
displayed full screen,
as if the navigation and
status bars are not there.
Set these flags on
onCreate, or at any point
after that in the lifecycle.
This lays out your
view from edge-to-edge.
By the way, if your app
users coordinator layout,
drawer layout, or a
similar layout, and sets
fit system windows true,
then the LAYOUT_STABLE
and LAYOUT_FULLSCREEN flags
are set automatically.
However, those views do not set
the LAYOUT_HEIGHT_NAVIGATION
flag.
Now, just to be safe, you
can set all three flags
all the time.
Also, if you're already
setting a combination of flags
on your layout, make sure you
don't wipe out your existing
flags.
For more details, watch the
"Becoming a Master Window
Fitter" talk by Chris Baines,
which I linked in the notes
below.
And that's it.
To ensure the best
user experience,
make sure your app
offers an edge-to-edge.
And watch the
gestural navigation
Dev Bite to learn more
about gestural navigation
and how to avoid conflicts
with the system home and back
gestures.
Thank you for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe
to the channel for more
awesome Android videos.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]